this movie uh jack and jill is uh katie
holmes who's married to tom cruise and
you you're like buddies with tom cruise
how did you meet him well how long have
you guys been friends i don't even know
how it would happen oh he hosted
saturday night live years ago and i got
to meet him there and uh he's a great
guy and we were at dinner
uh me and cruz and uh katie and my wife
and we were eating and uh we were
getting ready to shoot the picture and
uh he's uh he says this is weird that my
wife's gonna be your wife uh in the
movie that's very weird it's bizarre and
i was like it's a pg movie no worries
nothing nothing's gonna happen you know
that i said in fact anything
i do
with your wife in the movie you you can
do with my wife in real life
and so just every morning i would go to
a set and i'd hear my wife go please do
a love scene
[Applause]
my father in real life was not a very
wasn't selfish he was all about his
family
but then i think but i think the
weirdest thing he did was the the the
dog
oh yeah yeah he named the dog adam
you'd always say adam adam come in here
and i'd come in and go not you the dog
when i was a kid i was like i am going
to be in the military i'm going to
defend that's all i ever talked about in
my house like i'm going i i'm defending
i am this is what i'm made for and then
i was like 15 at the dinner table and i
was saying that same speech i can't wait
to join the military my father goes
you're not joining the military and i go
why not he goes because you're a [ __ ]
i got a girlfriend i read in the paper i
had a fiance but i don't i have a
girlfriend now she's
a very nice girl and uh she's younger
than you understand oh yeah but you're a
kid yourself i mean how old a guy are
you you're like in 24 or something like
that it's not like yeah i mean you have
very youthful appearance yeah i act
young yet yeah
i'm getting older i'm 32. yeah no she's
a eight year difference me and the girl
and so what would that be eight years
you're 32
i'm not sure but
i know this though and we figured out
that when she was five years old and
learning to read i was 13 and learning
to read
david uh by the way david we do this
little comedy tour we're running around
and i bring my kids sometimes on the
comedy tour
and we get on the plane and david
sometimes will be with a different lady
and
and you know i don't know what to say
anymore so
i just said
every time now my kids look they're like
is this the this is someone i just go
that's another one of david's sister
besides your face what body part do you
look at the most in the mirror
[Applause]
i
i don't want to look at it
but
the thing
all right i don't want to look at it at
all it just happens
that's what i see
this is the truth my grandfather was a
cab driver here in new york
for many years for like 30 years
yeah and uh so i was driving here
i took a cab to come here
and i
and i told the cab driver while i was
driving here i said hey buddy my
grandfather was a cab driver too so good
good job yeah he always told me a lot of
stories could you know you guys work
real hard and do great things for the
city way to go you know thanks man and
he turned back and he said death to all
jews
[Applause]
i mean that's what my grandfather used
to say
now your folks are in town
yes my folks are here they're staying
with you
they just came out here i'm very nervous
about that you see why why would you be
nervous get tense around my folks
because i want i love them so much i
want them to have a good time and i
don't know how to do anything i'm not a
good host you know normally i go home
and i you know i whatever they i go to
their life so i i say to my dad and i
said dad i'm nervous about you coming
and he goes don't be nervous we'll do i
said i don't know what you want to do
and he goes we'll do what you do we'll
adjust you do what you do and we'll do
what you do so apparently
this weekend they're going to lay in bed
and masturbate all day
long
[Applause]
so when i shot the movie i was so in and
excited about getting to know jewelry
and stuff and they gave me one of the
you know the loop thing the magnifier
magnifies the thing and so yeah i
started looking at everybody's jewelry
to see if it was good or bad and then
this is the weirdest thing i discovered
because of the loop i have a penis i had
no idea
my big sexual move the the only thing i
got on occasion i change speeds that's
about it
back and forth you know change pizza to
you know change it up a little bit you
know like i'll go slow fast slow that
kind of thing
and if they like that i'll give the
devil fast with a slow twist
who's a better kisser jen anderson or
drew barrymore
oh
tough one that can only break hearts
this answer so i'm gonna have to go with
chris rock
thanks i don't know if it's a great
story but my wife's grandmother
it's it's it get it it's okay it ends up
okay but my wife's grandma is 99 so
99. so we had a good lady
so we had a nice a birthday uh party for
for her
uh this past weekend and um
so anyway she's 99 and she's sleeping at
our house and in the middle of the night
uh i hear this terrifying scream
and
and i woke up uh oh something to happen
i go down and grandma fell and she fell
everything was all right she didn't get
badly hurt she just like uh hurt her
knee but it was okay and she was uh
frantic and who are you and it's adam
it's adam and nervous about everything
got her back to bed she was laughing by
the end everything was good so then the
next night
i'm laying in bed and i hear the same
scream and i was like oh
boy okay and that whole day during her
birthday i kept telling her it was my
birthday too as a joke i was saying why
is everybody celebrating your it's mine
too but she's like it is i said yeah
yeah and then the end of the night
the end of the night i told it's not
really my birthday so anyways i go
downstairs after the scream
and
she didn't fall this time she i said
grandma what happened she's like i had a
bad dream
and i said oh okay all right and she
goes who are you and i said it's adam
it's adam she goes happy birthday
swear to god
it was so funny
so i get to go to the greatest event but
my team's not there so it's just very
weird you know you just don't know what
to feel it's like
going to an orgy
and and just like there's no one you
really want to be with so you just kind
of sit in the middle and go hey
you guys do it do it have fun
do you find yourself repeating your
dad's habits so you because a little bit
yeah nothing happens doesn't it yeah
he's a great man i'm not as cool as my
old man but i'm stealing some of his
tricks like when he used to talk to my
mom he always every time he he gambled
on the golf course yeah and every time
he would say a number he would take a
zero off it that was his big move my
mother would say how much uh did you did
you bet me he'd say
thirty dollars and i knew it was three
hundred dollars
so now i kind of steal that thing at the
zero thing at my house with my girl
she'll say how many ice cream sandwiches
did you have i say two
[Music]
my dad's a very good golfer so i uh
i was golfing him a lot and it was nice
you know getting to see my dad a lot and
he bought me a putter he but all you
know i show up to the pro shop and he
goes i got you a putter kid and then he
gives me the putter and it says to my
best pal love dad on it and i was like
oh my god that's nice that's nice he's a
nice he's a nice dad
and uh
and so anyways i i play with the i put
and whatever but you know i go back out
to california away from my dad and the
thing is i it's not a good putter and uh
and i don't play very well with the
putter and it never goes well i i just
don't play well but i always see that to
my best pal love that on i'm like i
gotta gotta play with that flutter you
know i feel very guilty but finally like
five months later i called my dad up and
i said dad uh
i appreciate the gift it was very nice
here i love you uh it's just i don't
putt good with that putter and uh i was
wondering if i could maybe uh go get
another putter and he goes i gave you a
putter
dad
we're in oahu we're having a great time
i've always got to force my kids to get
out of the pool and go to the to the
beach i'm like let's go to the beach if
you got a pool at home come on let's get
in the hawaiian water so i don't wanna
it's rough the water's rough i said it's
fine blah blah blah i buy them two tubes
that they can sit in i i'm like just sit
in the tubes but you know do that do
that so my my big one is my ten-year-old
she's sitting in the tube and i'm
watching and i'm videoing her and i'm
wise i'm videoing i'm like this looks
like a big wave coming
and
i'm like oh god no and she gets she's
perfectly facing the way gets hit does a
flip
lands on her feet but i can see she
shook up wow if he lands on her feet
like we would not expect that to happen
but she lands on her feet i'm videoing
and i just and i go i i better say
something quick i go i got that on video
and like
she was so happy oh she was she gets
tricked into like oh yeah that was
supposed to happen i go come here look
at that i'll show you and she's like
yeah i landed on my feet i'm like that's
right you did
you're the greatest you're a gymnast
no crying then literally a minute later
my other one
same position i can see the wave coming
i'm just watching boom flip
she looks
terrified looks back at me did you get
that
have you ever when's the last time you
got pulled over
i get pulled over
sometimes and we have nice conversations
how does it work you know ah pretty
pretty good works out pretty good
driver's license registration and then
you say well
it usually
it goes
like sir do you know sandman
first grade
i had a little crush on miss colettis i
wouldn't raise my hand to go to the
bathroom i would pee myself
and how is that a move here's how it
worked
because then she had to change me
whenever she was changing me i was like
here we are
[Laughter]
my two daughters are little and they
fall asleep in the bed with me and my
wife a lot and so they're always there
and they're the best and i love them
more than they snuggle with you and all
that stuff but you know i am a grown man
i do like to have sex and so i
i mean well this is the place to call
attention to that right here
he's a grown man
he likes to have sex
no i mean
all right
so
so anyways i'm lying in bed with with
the wife and the two kids are sleeping
next that's the wife i call it
and so we're laying there and we're both
up and two kids asleep and i was like
hey you know we could let's pull this
can we do this here and she's like no
you don't do that with the kids in the
bed i was like i i don't move that much
i'm not going to wake them you know but
but i didn't uh
you know i'm not a flexible guy so
anyway she says no we're not doing that
you can get arrested or whatever so i
say all right
so
anyway so i say can we go down the hall
they're not using their beds right so
why not now that makes perfect sense
thank you david i knew you'd back me up
so uh
so anyways we get into my littlest kids
bed and
flipped the lights off and i went at it
pretty good and
i
i did some serious damage in there and
uh
after
the fact i said wasn't that great wasn't
that worth it and she goes what watching
you bang elmo
it wasn't her oh
but
but i told i told my wife i really did
think it was you and i did a great job
and then i i finished the deal because
it was the first time i ever heard you
say
so anyways i i was at dinner with steve
buscemi this is like 25 years ago or
something we were sitting
at dantanas and eating and then rickles
came over to us and we're like oh my god
this is this is happening right now and
he says to bushemy
something like uh i you know maybe 23
whatever years ago he says something
about
i saw your movie
uh mr pink
more like mr stink or something like
that and blue
shield and then he laughs and he goes
ooh maybe get some braces
oh my god
and then he sees me and he goes ooh and
you
all right hey how you doing he's like i
think it was happy gilmore somebody goes
so happy gilbert watch the whole thing
wow amazing how no talent can get you a
movie
yes yes
the big the thing i noticed is uh i'm
getting older and a little uh you know
my body has changed over the last few
years it's not as not not good it's not
as good it's not it was never awesome
but it was uh it was better you know
and i remember in what regard is it is
it changing it's getting a little bit
thicker
but everything still works though right
oh yeah that stuff's all right
it's not it's not very good i use it but
it doesn't i don't use it right i guess
i've never heard anyone say good job
but um but here's the thing that i
noticed with the getting a little uh not
as handsome and a little the body you're
not as good
and then my shirt coming off now when i
was younger and if i was
whatever if i was with a girl i was
whatever and we were moving on to that
level and i had to take my shirt off i
was almost looking forward to it i was
like
hey i'm going to surprise her with this
pretty good deal that's right check this
out not only yourself yeah
pretty funny and and look at the abs
yeah
now i'm uh with my girl i take my shirt
off i'm like
at least i'm nice
you're being too hard on yourself